this is son of the mask son of a bitch
shit just hug your monkey man hug it
monkey I hate this is a family show
family pictures that were started I
think it's nervous on the mast in it
that worry didn't I think so I mean I we
got I thought I actually I know but I
thought we'd I thought we made that
reference much earlier no we quoted it
but we never worked in tour we never
worked into it yeah I think that's the
first one where I put what is it with
such terrifying imagery in what's
supposed to be a Soviet yeah if you want
to know where that reference came from
um what's the commentary for watch the
commentary for Wizards the Ralph Beth
Bakshi movie um I may say Bosch key just
cuz it's easier to say no I think
everyone always thinks on st. Bosch key
but it's a peck it's hard to say back so
I try to be like yeah see I try to
emphasize about she like a she so it's I
actually like Wizards it's it's a it's a
batshit back his shit crazy it's a gum
Ralph back Beck she movie it's a yeah
back shit Chris it's a it's at that's
why I said okay so back shit crazy um
it's a guilty pleasure it's like late
seventies what the fuck kind of like
early Mark Hamill role to he was a voice
actor in it and yeah I I think was
George Carlin and then it sounded like
it our Peter Falk herself Peter Falk or
somebody yeah anyway good if you just
like weird animation really weird
animation look it up but it's a movie
that it definitely has an adult feel
there's very Gore Nazis Knotts Nazi
propaganda films a gas warfare like
rotoscoped footage of people getting
arrow shot through their heads a woman
with like covered in Pratt just young
scarves going down the grass and then to
her crotch with nothing else like makes
Lilu from fulfillment look fully clothed
like ready to go to the ball um and so
like I I'd seen this movie number times
and finally I wig I got the DVD and
we're watching this and like he's going
on and on about huh you know why I he's
got like this mean it's a Jersey accent
but with alou wrongs Bronx New York
issue yeah kind of
New York is an cities I know I always
want to make a picture for the kids for
the families I always want to make a you
know a family picture and so this is my
chance to do a family picture and he
kept saying sickenin again and we just
kept looking at each other like is he
serious yeah like this is really just a
family yeah this is Becky's family
picture and so like whenever we see
something that is wildly inappropriate
because you can see their family picture
you know with Nazis in their Furies with
big titties you know Shep with the
kitties only a pic so whenever we see a
movie for years we've been doing this
over over 10 years um whatever we see
movie that is why it has something
wildly inappropriate for kids in it and
it tends to be airing yeah or scary
you're tens of you kids film Tucket I
would always turn to each other goat you
know a family bit shit yes a picture no
picture yeah a family picture so finally
this made it I guess into some of the
masks I thought we had done it earlier
because we say it all the time but yeah
we said to ourself what we never
actually put in watching and phil ivey
that this would be this is the spot to
use this is such a terrifying movie
watching NCS we had probably said it
multiple times because there's so many
inappropriate jokes or something that
didn't belong in these kids movies that
we had been seeing so or were too scary
or weird or whatever when this is one of
those films where it's like there is
technically a story but somewhere in the
middle it's just like you know we're not
going to really story's more of a side
thing we're just gonna show a bunch of
weird imagery and these little chases
and stuff that really have nothing to do
with anything but whatever I'm a
director and it's the late 90s early
2000s and the peak then think that was
just I to show that I'm an individual
and I'm different and thank god that's
dying but I'll let you actually talked
mostly about this cuz I a my voice is
kind of going I was doing Jeremy Irons
earlier for the nostalgia critic which
because ever asked me this flash on
hurts yeah I can't even do it now
because my voice is thrown and we just
took care of bears but I don't remember
a lot of this movie oh I just I just saw
I but you were talking about oh yeah
poor Ellen Cummings in this role and Bob
Hoskins oh I forgot they were fucking
this movie well Bob Hoskins has a la
makeup on but he's kind of like a
Yosemite Sam of the gods all I
remembered was I hated it and was so
bored and was pretty much like doing
this just like make it stop it's one of
those where you know you got all the
circuitry P imagery going on and it's a
sequel to the mask which way it was
pg-13 but not for it's scary imagery
because of some sex innuendos I don't
know this was PG or pg-13 but it's it
deserves to be an hour because it's so
awful and it deserves to be an ex a way
like nobody goes yeah um but it's one of
those where there yeah there's just kind
of this time where I think for a while
there's this thought going on that like
you know sir these children's films and
Brian comedies and comic book films and
stuff we're still seeing is like kids
stuff you know like oh they're not to be
taken seriously so people without their
ways and kind of like both comics and
movies to try and be really dark with
stuff that probably didn't really need
to be sometimes it paid off
you know like with uh with play that was
a lot of fun being very dark and stuff
like that but then you have stuff like
southern mask where it's like just
clearly they're trying to like get this
style across and the directors trying to
be like notice me notice me and now such
a big part of the early 2000s in the
late 90s and thankfully we're getting
back into an election Shyamalan ya know
a shaman is what I think one of you
still doing that you know the note is my
direction thing and that's entirely what
this is it was also during the point
where a low starting to dive out here
but there is a point where wide-angle
lens was everywhere like fucking
everywhere was all over 90s commercials
it was all over movies it was just all
over the place
and it just wouldn't stop it was just
all friggin over the place and this is
the one that question mister here yes
mr. monkey why was wide angle lunge
everywhere because it made things look
weird and distorted and again people
thought like oh I'm the next Terry
Gilliam because I'm looking weird
and artsy and that's what everybody
tried to do everyone want to be at East
but Terry Gilliam's movies never rarely
ever make money so why would you want to
imitate somebody that is not doing well
on the blockbuster scene because they
want to be Otis and people let them do
it for some reason uh I don't know it's
really stupid service or monkey now shut
up oh don't don't do that now you see
that this is this is about is visit of a
charity level of son of the mask
actually so think we're more mature but
it's one of those things where and they
try to get in which I mean you're
talking to the people that love return
to Oz I mean love babe pig in the city
love films
I like that mask yeah no no that love
films that have like scary imagery for
kids if it's done right and done with
purpose and you know works to the
benefit of the story this doesn't this
is meant to be a dumb slapstick movie
like the mask which is fine I really
like the man she feeling but I don't
even remember any of the scary imagery I
am not lying I literally remember hardly
anything about this movie there's lots
of scary imagery in it and you know just
like surreal like we're just gonna make
you uncomfortable watching this and
shoot it on ugly colors and wide-angle
lenses and stuff and a part of me like
some of those shots like whatever uh
whoever it was talking down to Loki the
Bob Hoskins uh was talking down to Loki
like some of those shots are so
imaginative and strange it actually kind
of looks like a Terry Gilliam cartoon
it's kind of cool that's okay but then
one is I know we got to make it really
creepy and really scary it's you don't
need to you don't need to express with
your dark side you know that always
seemed to be the thing for a while um so
I remember watching it now saying myself
because it was just so hard to figure
out what to say to all these scenes I
just said you know this feels like what
the devil would show its kid like
somewhere and we just start I like maybe
that's what happened like the devil was
supposed to show his kid their version
of a kid's film and it accidentally got
lost somewhere and maybe we accidentally
picked it up you forgot the wrong
version somebody called Eve only
ya know that's pretty much what happened
I was like alexengel yeah shut up
um so proof I don't like you either
but yeah it's one of those things where
it's like so that's where that idea came
about and I Drive idiot Jamie Kennedy
really he's a leading man there's a
funny thing I've been completely
indifferent to Jamie Kennedy all my life
this didn't help fix that problem
I left that movie just like wow talk
about something that leaves no
impression I you know I don't know with
people like you know maybe he's a
talented person somewhere else II you
know just this clearly is in the movie
to show it he did do a film though about
like it's called hecklers which sounds
great it sounds like I would love to see
I'd love to see hecklers going I'd love
to see them get their comeuppance I'd
love to see documentary about hecklers
but then it turns out that's only like
the first 10 minutes and then he segues
into critics and then how critics are
really the hecklers and bad people and
that the bed people really didn't like
his movies and that those critics should
be ashamed of themselves there's like ah
now I get it
somebody's got issues no and the point
cause he's in really shitty movie and
nobody likes especially critter you know
for someone who's voice is sore you seem
to be doing that very scratchy painful I
hate to listen to what hi this is um so
I just can't get deep and rasmus so it's
one of those things where it's like
nobody's ah this is actually be doing
Mickey that's how you know the voice is
so that's your diffic gone yes sorry I
just
hi derail this just cuz I don't like
talking about it brings back bad
memories it's like a little iterator
from your mind you don't want to think
I've obliterated it but all you know
it's left its I've obliterated any
memory of the movie but when you mention
the word son of the mask
I feel bad it's really what good I just
I remember I remember this much I
remember sitting on your couch and I
remember having like coffee next to me
and I remember just constant
like adjusting my some of you have one
of those couches or you like recline
remember climbing for a while I'm like
and we were sitting up I'm like everyone
like no matter what I just felt
uncomfortable and I realized that for
why was just the movie the movie was
just making me feel bad and you know
there was just a bad feeling from the
start with this week because first of
all I mean I obviously didn't get any of
the actors from the original outside of
Ben Stein I'm sure the dogs dead um you
know they didn't get any of the original
actors and it wasn't thought they don't
play that in fact there was some H I
think what movie was coming out I think
was men in black maybe you're some sort
of midnight screening we went to I think
was men in black there's a lot of people
as movies really hype to people really
excited to see it and they had a preview
for son of the mask and just a teaser
and it was just like oh men in black -
right I don't know minimum like that
would have been like 1997 dude isn't
that thought this came out like late I
thought this came up oh no no you know
you know you movie so forgettable we can
t remember the romantic whatever was
there some sort of movie I thought it
was later than that there's some sort of
movie that was coming out that was a big
deal and I just merde the film be the
fear being jam-packed and this trailer
comes out and it shows that the most
ultimate weapon the most incredible
whatever in the back off and it's the
mask well kid mask big was a pile of
wood we don't care who's in it and so
and it will be passed on to the next
person is I it just shows this little
baby if you're the dude dude and it's
like everyone's just looking it's like
how can I look at it and you just see
the baby there and it holds on this baby
for like five solid seconds of him doing
nothing and then like this horrible CG
effective in like jumping on the chair
going hey and they're going up to the
camera guy doing the eyebrow thing and
like that's that's all they have and but
that's all you needed to know yeah dad
told me right there kiba's I'm gonna
fucking like this movie is only gonna
rely on look the mask was given to a
baby you like baby jokes what nobody
does nobody fucking likes baby jokes
well he's the star Jamie Kennedy says
you're just being a nasty heckler Oh
critics our and we'll be watching the
show I remember watching it and it had
that Ally McBeal baby type quality - I'm
just like wow
really doing the joke kind of this old
like we got the CGI cartoon baby it just
got like what you guys have never seen
this before right we can do this with CG
have a baby go baby
does that maybe that's why you think it
was 1997 because that whole thing felt
like ally mcbeal's like man this is so
1997 could be I don't know it yeah I
just remember thinking when I saw that
you're a this looks like shit I was like
be you know what way it's all said and
done I would rather mass go to the dog
like that's all I thought it was like
nobody gets it - yeah and he gets it -
but I'm like just make the whole movie
about the dog I don't need Jimmy Kennedy
I don't need the baby just give it to
the dog make it a ten-minute short throw
it before a much better movie
end of story if you told me there is a
movie with you know Ellen coming Stephen
right Bob Hoskins fucking a sign me up
for this and it's like no no they're all
pushed aside not allowed to do anything
I'd say that sounds like the Super Mario
Brothers sequel we know right as the
villain I am King Koopa monkey I am the
porch I am a toad it blows bubbles for
some reason this is all a dream it
doesn't make any sense
that's all I can think about just Steven
Wright as the wart from Mario Brothers -
um somebody make that happen
yeah I would drink ha skis back to life
and say this know better it's me warrior
I love Steven Wright I did horribly
miscast in every movie he's in but man
what a stain no no no he was an orphan
18 vanadium back that's right for
Solomon waiting today to be bacon and
gonna wear my bars you what are you
talking about um so yeah so it just felt
like one of those movies where it's like
it's trying to show off some effects
that they thought were amazing it's
trying to be all kooky I think it's
trying to be like Beetlejuice maybe I
think like when that movie came out or
going on week
do this and there's a director that I
don't even put the words I mask and
Beetlejuice in the same sentence no but
I think that's well often we're trying
to do for a while it's sort of do like
what Tim Burton did cuz Tim Burton is
one of the few directors who can make
fucking millions of dollars but still be
Tim Burton be make any artistic movie he
wants to because we'll watch that
weirdness and I try to be that next
weird director you might be onto
something but I think it's better to say
Beetlejuice by way of men in black like
I think everybody wanted to cash in on
that quirky men in black but also people
who yeah which was not really Beatle G
it odd some stuff to burden a lot of
Barry Sonnenfeld they cover similar
territory they both used Bo Welch like
but yeah I feel like more men and black
like quirky hip kind of and just God I
like the first mask that's what kills me
yeah the first mattress mask again is
better than has a right to be yeah its
weight its ever gonna win any awards for
being a great great movie but it's
actually just just dumb fun and it's one
of the few like really likeable Jim
Carrey roles like it and I don't say
like well just cuz I Jim Carrey
automatically I hate him but like even a
lot of times in Jim Carrey roles where
he's good he's still playing a jerk or
something and this one he's a completely
nice guy and I side with was it Cisco
where was it Ebert I think both we had
both of them implied and both of them
said pretty much that they liked the
ipkiss character better than me I when I
was a kid I liked the mask now I like
that and and Stanley if kisses character
it's still one of the great Jim Carrey
roles honestly I think stanley ipkiss
his character is probably what ended up
landing him The Truman Show because
whenever I watched The Truman Show I see
it as kind of an extension of what he
was doing in the mask with the ipkiss
character eases very nice genial little
fake but you know it works for what it
is and the effects in the mask were good
the story was silly but it and I don't
that's the other thing I don't feel like
it was a movie intended for little kids
little kids could see but I feel like
you know like 13 year olds like what we
were it was a comic book movie it
basically it was a comic book movie so
kids could see it adults could see it
teenagers could see we're probably the
perfect age
13y I was in love yeah um so I mean
Devon I mean definitely not as dark as
the graphic novel you do magic that
movie was made today the graphic never
had so much more plating Omar you will
be a terrible is there that movie apart
can imagine it came out today and it's
like shitting bricks every night can you
beam empty space up when that wires
Walter don't be rough for comics fucking
oh I love the comment because amazingly
like terribly gory and awful it just
like the worst of humanity but it
totally embraces it and it's a gripping
story surprisingly um but yeah it's a
bit of a difference cuz like I can
already hear Viva game but you did make
me do kimby because you didn't hear me
if going you feeling like you don't want
to come to a bed I wasn't gonna ask but
it's a better movie though that's all
I'm gonna say is like straight even he
took off what'll come in on if you
boring don't movie yeah whereas I think
the mask is pretty good yeah
no the mask stands on its own if
anything just for toil yeah the only
part I started losing the mask is on the
bad guy put so it's like oh I'm like
okay this is really fuck even in okay
this is really fucking Stu my favorite
thing just from a plot point like from a
narrative perspective is in themes is
like oh is it Cameron Diaz is Cameron
Diaz here the ants like Thank You
Stanley for treating me like a human
being and now this sex object I'm like
well it's pretty much what he did
whenever the mask was on yeah she seemed
to like it I'm like okay like you know
there was a weird like medication with
zombie yeah but but it's still a lot of
fun like it's clearly a currency like
yeah it's a cartoon I can forgive it
because it's it yeah it it's hearts in
the right place yeah this one clearly is
trying to like it's somebody or a big
group of people just trying to be like
you know weird and expressive and get a
job at a terry gilliam film pretty much
in so many years I think that's anything
which is why I'm really sure was not
1997 you saw that you're probably right
it is because I felt like when it came
out I'm just like it was another one
those projects where it's like wow this
is years too late it was like Indiana
Jones oh ya know when they announced
Indy for I'm just like well maybe to be
good I had no idea but the one thing
that worried me was like we are so late
in the game here and like the Sun and
the math I was another I'm like this is
way too many years lay on my mothering
doing this like you needed to get this
out before 1998 there had to be 97
no there had to be talks of making the
math dude no because there was a thing
on the Barbara Walters interview he said
I'm getting X amount for the mask too so
like it was and that's like before
Batman Forever came out I think you know
so it's like it was in the works and
then contracts or something couldn't
match up and I think it was like
Catwoman it was probably just like
tossed from place to place and writer
the writers duties to the fellows from
creative creator in a desperate attempt
to say no kind of and then finally you
know what just do something with him
sick of looking at just I think
everybody was sick of looking at and you
got Halle Berry in a terrible outfit you
know a movie that has nothing to do with
what it was starting out as and I think
the mask do you know mr. heretic maybe
they should just cut their losses then
and say you know what maybe just wasn't
it to happen and that voice some shitty
ass iguanas god knows how many days
later well then we won't have the
masterpiece the thief and the cobbler um
pretty much the same thing happen with
that they're probably just like you know
no just you and when you see the
original cut uh you know at least and at
some gorgeous anime oh it did yes
no it's all those things like the son of
the mask know when you see like whatever
the final cut of that movie with all the
storyboards and everything like you can
see like the last half hour is just like
one giant wily coyote machine and how it
works and it's it's incredible from an
animation standpoint but it's like he's
fucking insane who the hell would give
all this money to this uh so it's one of
those things we sir look at it's like
well yeah that would have been better
but it's against colleague Wizards are
Fritz the cat or something like that
it's just an insane experiment and you
can understand someone just being okay
just get rid of it finish it by god I
think the point is don't remake like
don't do a sequel so many years later
unless your journey like George Miller
and doing Mad Max fury road he's the
only one that could pull it off that's
right and the moral of the story is fuck
son of the mask and go see bad max fury
road cuts don't fucking amazing I've
only seen like dirty three times oh I
want to see it again what am i time on
set on the bass we're gonna be watching
Gary room god damn you this is your
fault
hey stop it sorry who's the monkey this
is what you do in your spare time
yes well I'm gonna go before the monkey
spanked me some more if those supposed
to be the other way around but clearly I
was wrong
um so yeah nothing much else to say it's
son of the fucking mask
it's like declared by many as one of the
worst movies of all time so I you know
what I was it is it is so bad I can't
remember it like I have images but
that's it and like I know I will give
some like there's always the weird
distinctive people like oh well can the
head is your least favorite of Garbage
Pail Kids but there is something about
those I'm like well they were so
amazingly awful
I kind of remember where some the mask
is so bad in a certain way that it's
just so forgettable hmm I'm like wow
that's that's special when I can't even
remember seeing your damn movie I just
remember a movie really trying to show
off when it had nothing to show off
that's the first thing that pops into my
head um and there's a lot of it and I
don't want to think about it so that's
not anymore that's it kids go home see
my max what a day max my name is max